les policiers indiens exit devant les
caméras une trentaine de fraudeurs
arrêtés lors d'une rafle dans un centre
d'appels clandestins ils ont saisi des
téléphones et des ordinateurs ainsi
qu'une liste de 600 victimes canadiennes
tomber dans le panneau
l agence du revenu du canada va exécuter
un mandat d'arrestation et vous risquez
la prison si vous ne rappelait pas à ce
numéro prétendent les fraudeurs
depuis des années de nombreux canadiens
ont reçu cet appel de menaces cet homme
qui souhaite garder l'anonymat s'en veut
d'avoir donné trente six mille dollars à
des fraudeurs comme lui des milliers de
personnes ont mordu à l'hameçon
malgré les mises en garde de l'agencé du
revenu en cet appel tequila renâcle
malheureusement certaines personnes se
sont à voir car ces manifs la ministre
quant à elle se réjouit de ces
arrestations
elle rappelle au canadien de demeurer
vigilants ce pauvre est que l'agencé va
appeler les gens pour leur dire écoutez
si vous nous donnez pomme nous fait pas
inversement immédiatement on va envoyer
la police chez vous et on va vous mettre
en prison ça se passe pas de 7 passant
l'eau à lagence la grc promets de
travailler pour que les victimes
canadiennes puissent retrouver une
partie de l'argent volé la ministre du
revenu ne veut rien promettre non plus
ça va être avec elle et avec la grc puis
au niveau le dé la justice le lait quel
dossier va se poursuivre mais faut pas
être trop optimiste
je suis dit rien qui irait du travail à
faire au moins une dizaine de centres
d'appels clandestins seraient toujours
en fonction emmène la grc assure qu'elle
mettra de la pression pour que les
autorités indiennes serre la vis aux
fraudeurs il suffit de vincent foisy
radio canada ottawa